vous pensiez qu'un jour il y a quelqu'un
comme ça qui fera un beau cantine très
bien que les jeunes femmes
une jeune fille toute sexy donc un rêve
dans la vie c'est jouer
génial ça s'appelle les Vénus de mélo
c'est bien c'est toi qui a trouvé ça ah
oui
il y en a 31 autres parce qu'il y a 30
qui arrivera
c'est 33 alors je voulais qu'il ait 33
filles qui ont bercé mon enfance mes
amours et mes rêves et qui m'ont appris
à mail cinéma qui m'ont appris à même
plein de choses et je trouvais que
c'était normal de rendre hommage à des à
des femmes qui m'ont fait rêver et qui
compte diminue maintenant à travailler
et à faire rêver d'une autre après tu as
pas eu envie de faire un livre sur
Béatrice Dalle Valérie caprisky Juliette
binove
graphique et pas des membres
premièrement elle m'intéresse
modernement moi j'ai eu la chance ou le
port de mes rencontré pour des papiers
ou dans l'idée ou dans Paris Match elles
m'ont pas fait rêver du coup et ça
repose pas sur des souvenirs d'enfance
alors que mon livre là avec Mylène
Demongeot et France anglaise et 31
autres ça repose sur des on se tient je
veux dire et ça repousse des souvenirs
d'enfance des amours de jeunesse vous
pensiez qu'un jour il y a quelqu'un
comme ça qui fera un beau cantine
que les jeunes femmes
jeunes filles du sexy donc un rêve dans
la vie c'est jouer donc
déchaîné l'amour de millions de femmes
c'était une chose mais nous nous avions
envie d'être à tous je parle de nous
droit de la plupart d'entre nous et
maintenant vous avez je m'aperçois que
ça fait rigoler tout le monde parce que
quand vous avez cet âge-là et que les
gens rêvent sur vous on en a absolument
rien à [ __ ] pour essayer avec lui ou
pas il y a il y a un divorce que je veux
la chemise par rapport au futur et
l'homme qui est amoureusement au cinéma
simplement parce qu'il tombe que vous
avez une avancée superbe un cul sublime
et une peau de nacre c'est très très
marrant des fois mon sapeur
d'excitation c'est la Salomé d'Oscar
Wilde qui la seule pièce il est écrit en
français et qu'on va créer au théâtre
moutarde à partir du 1er mars ça
n'existait parce qu'ils font ça
absolument être très bien la très en
je cherche une pièce moi aussi
la démarche est différente j'aimerais
jouer avec ma fille
oui elle va être finir
j'ai pas trop fixé il faut des rapports
de mer et filles qui soient pas trop
dramatique on peut s'amuser toutes les
deux alors les gens est-ce que c'est un
bouquin qui doit être rangé dans une
bibliothèque ou qui doit servir à des
réalisateurs pour choisir des modèles
mais certainement pas je veux dire bon
on peut le lire et là en train de
bibliothèque ça me paraît évident mais
on peut aussi surtout le feuilleter et
moi ce que je voudrais ce que je devrais
faire c'est ma maison d'édition de
l'autorisée c'est l'envoyer à tous les
déréateurs et producteurs du cinéma
français
parce qu'il y en a qui tourne Mylène
tourne encore France arrête de te
tourner mais ça devrait il y a des gens
qui sont des crétins je veux dire quand
on les voit les 33 bon il y en a
quelques-unes qui sont décédés comme
Daniel Gobert ou comme François
d'Orléans mais elles sont belles je sais
pas que les caméras elles sont belles
comme les amours qu'on leur donne des
rôles déjà
moi si j'avais un agent comme ça
et pour pour ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu